now Spain has just recorded a record
jump in daily deaths from coronavirus
anywhere in the world 950 people as
we've been saying have died in the past
24 hours
bringing the toll there to more than
10,000 with another 8,000 people
infected in the last day the number of
confirmed cases has now surpassed a
hundred and ten thousand these latest
numbers put Spain on par with Italy
well now Marta Herrera is joining me
live from Madrid Marta even more
sobering figures today and not only a
new record for Spain but the world - yes
in Russia 950 coronavirus dead in Spain
since yesterday again the deadliest day
and with more than 10,000 in total the
death rate rises to 9.0 7% more than 800
new infections reaching 110 thousand of
people that have tested positive from
coronavirus in Spain the 13 percent of
these people still remain the health
care workers being the health care
workers they still lack of medical
supplies like testing most of them many
of them are are battling in the
frontline of this virus without the
protective measures with symptoms
without knowing whether they're positive
or not and they're still running out of
this gear
despite the supply of the Spanish
government this week and distribution in
all regions it's not enough they've made
an in statement saying they don't want
to become heroes or marteze they just
want to deploy the task or the duties
and work in safe conditions and matter
it also seems there's no respite for
spamming on top of the ongoing battle
with the virus and these awful figures I
see now some very disheartening numbers
came out just in the last few hours when
it comes to jobs - yes the concept of
economic consequences of coronavirus
have caused a big impact in Spain we
woke up this morning with 900,000 jobs
have been lost in the last within the
last two weeks since March 12 and two
years of job creation have been lost
because of this so now we have the
unemployment rate in where we have the
unemployment people in Spain four point
five million people that have lost their
job in Spain the worst rate since 2002
Marta Herrera there for us in the
Spanish capital thank you very much
Marta
well let's now get more on just how
residents in Spain are handling the
outbreak we can speak to Magua Lera
vacas who's a professor of
constitutional law at Barcelona
University but she joins us now from
Aguada a city under one of the most
restrictive lockdowns
in Spain ma thank you so much for taking
the time to speak to us today I know the
lockdown in your city has been described
as a lockdown within a lockdown and
you've been living inside it for three
weeks now by my count can you describe
for us what life is like there at the
moment yes we are locked down inside a
lockdown so the situation here is
strange because we cannot get out from
our seedy little city guada and it's not
only that we cannot go to get out from
our house but since before the lockdown
that was passed all over Spain we were
already locked down here in Aguada but
at the beginning we could go out for for
a walk keeping the the social distance
we could go for a walk in the
countryside because this is a small
industrial city so we could go go for
walks but after the Spanish government
passed the alarm state we cannot get out
from our home and then we cannot go out
from our city from our area so this is
kind of a strange and the other thing is
that it's reasonable we cannot get out
from our area because we are a focus but
then we don't understand why other
series did not get locked down although
I can understand that there are cities
that are more difficult to lock down
rather than a city like mine which is a
smaller but there still I we don't get
why these differences happened of course
I know that other residents of your city
have been speaking about a sense of duty
self-sacrifice throughout this period
what's the mood there now after so many
weeks especially I believe your
isolation has been doubled from 15 days
to 30 days now yes
for this the government needs the
approval from the Parliament from the
Spanish Parliament from the Spanish
Congress and the Congress accepted this
largeman so the first 15 days the
government just needed to inform the
Parliament but to a large sheet for 15
days more they needed approval from the
Parliament by a simple majority and then
this is what happened that they enlarged
the confinement then we were not sure if
we will get rid of one of our
confinements which is read from the fact
that we are also confined here in Aguada
and the other villages nearby but no the
the new decree that was passed by the
government said that we kept being
confined here in Aguada which maybe it's
not maybe it's not crucial because we
are already here at home but that means
that if something happens if we want to
go to another hospital we would need
authorization even if we need to see our
relatives or there are in some cases
inside the decree you can move around
but not if you are from Aguada
or from the other towns like Villa Nova
Delta me or Modena so if you are one of
the persons living either in Iguala the
villa nova alchemy mabui or olena you
cannot get out from from these towns
sure no I do want to ask because I see
the numbers are pretty large there
something like 20,000 infections and the
hospital they're incredibly
overstretched
I imagine everyone there probably knows
at least one person who's been infected
or has passed on how are people their
coping day-to-day psychologically it's
it's really tough we are a scare and I
really would recommend people from all
over the world to really keep the social
distance because when this is started
before already knew what was happening
in in Italy but we couldn't believe it
but we already had some small cases here
so I would repel everybody to keep the
social distance because it's the only
way because when they will be a
the situation would had will have been
exploded so it's very important that
everybody stays at home and keeps a
social distance because now what's
happening here is that people cannot go
to funerals they can not stay with their
relatives that when they are see the the
hospitals are back so and then there are
many many deaths like last year in 2019
47% side here in Nevada this new year a
hundred and forty so there is a
difference so even the numbers we have
they are they are dancing because they
are not real because there are many
people that has passed away without
being the diagonals
they organized as commit 2:19 muggle
Arivaca is there speaking to us from ego
Val ego a lava a city under one of the
most restrictive lockdowns in Spain
thank you for joining us